Pablo Escobar
Pablo Escobar was the world’s most successful
drug trafficker.
He was also its most deadly.
During his 17- year reign at the top of the
Colombian cocaine empire, he ordered the killings
of thousands of people, including judges,
ministers of parliament and Presidential candidates.
At the height of his power he was raking in
over a million dollars a day, yet in the end
he was forced to live as a fugitive in the
Colombian jungle.
Shot down on a rooftop in the city that he
had ruled over, his was a fall from grace
of epic proportion.
In this week’s Biographics, we go deep into
the South American drug world to reveal the
true-life story of Don Pablo.
Early Life
Pablo Emilio Escobar Gaviria was born on December
1st, 1949 in the small town of Rinegro, 45
minutes from Medellin, Colombia.
His father, Abel, was a hard working, humble
cattle farmer, while his mother Hermilda was
a school teacher.
Pablo, the second of seven children, was raised
in a middle-class environment in a community
that was fuelled by the cocaine and marijuana
trade.
Although not everyone directly participated
in the drug business, they all had a powerful
incentive in the protection of those that
did.
The violence that was part and parcel of enforcing
the narcotics trade was all around.
Before Pablo started school, the family moved
to Envigado, a small village just out of Medellin,
so that Hermilda could establish an elementary
school there.
Abel sold the farm and took up a job as a
neighbourhood watchman.
Through her work at the school, Hermilda soon
become a popular and well-respected member
of the community.
At school, Pablo proved himself to be an able
and quick-witted student.
Although tending toward the chubby side, thanks
to his love of fast food, he was talented
in all ball sports, with a special love for
soccer.
Many of his teachers were involved in social
causes, especially the struggle for class
equality and they became powerful influences
on the boy.
By the time he was in his early teens, Pablo
was attending street rallies and participating
in such activities as throwing rocks at the
police.
Pablo became part of a youth culture movement
known as Nadaismo which encouraged young people
to thumb their noses at the established order,
disobey their parents and write their own
rules.
Part of this counterculture movement involved
experimentation with drugs, leading the thirteen-year-old
future drug kingpin to develop an addiction
to marijuana which would never leave him.
The Young Thug
By the age of sixteen Pablo had developed
into a plump, short youth, standing at just
over five foot, six inches.
He had a round face and wore a slight moustache.
A couple of months before reaching his seventeenth
birthday, he dropped out of school, bored
with the straight-laced routine and keen to
make his own way in the world.
After quitting school, the enterprising Pablo
started up a little bicycle repair shop.
He would prowl the streets and the local dump
in search of discarded bicycle parts and then
use them to fix bikes for cheap.
With the money that he made from this enterprise,
he purchased himself a Lambretta motorcycle.
Now with a means of fast escape, he began
planning how to make money more easily than
repairing bicycles for a pittance.
According to legend, Pablo’s foray into
crime began with him stealing headstones from
the local cemetery, sandblasting the names
from them and then reselling them.
Pablo decided that the route to quick cash
lay in commercial business robbery.
He started by scoping out potential targets.
He would then ride to the target business
on his motorbike, slip a balaclava over his
head and rush the business with a knife or
gun in hand, demand the money and then get
out of there.
It all happened in about 30 seconds.
After a few successful robberies, Pablo recruited
his cousin to join him.
One would ride the bike and act as the get
away rider while the other stormed the business.
Within a few months, Pablo became bored with
this and moved on to bigger – and easier
– things.
He established a contact with a Renault car
dealer who would provide him with copies of
the keys to the cars that he had just sold,
along with the addresses of the buyers.
All that Pablo had to do was turn up at the
addresses and drive the cars away.
In his late teens, Pablo got caught in the
act of stealing one of these cars.
He ended up spending several months in La
Ladera Jail, which was to him, a positive
life experience.
Here he learned about how to move into bigger
time criminal activity, including kidnapping
and drug trafficking.
A Violent Reputation
Once back on the street, Pablo and his cousin
Gustavo went right back to stealing cars.
They built up a collection of stolen engine
parts which they would sell off bit by bit.
The pair took to building race cars, with
Pablo competing in local events.
Pablo and Garcia weren’t the only ones stealing
cars in Medellin, which led to an extension
of his operation.
He decided to also sell protection, so that
people would pay him to ensure that their
car did not get taken.
Pablo was able to provide such a service because
he had developed a reputation as an unpredictable
and violent young man.
If anyone owed him money, Pablo would hire
some local thug to kidnap the person.
He would them ransom him for whatever was
owed to him.
From time to time he would have the person
killed even when the ransom was paid, simply
to engender fear in those he dealt with.
Before long, Pablo decided to specialise in
kidnappings for their own sake.
Along with his cousin and future brother-in-law
he nabbed a rich businessman by the name of
Diego Echavarria.
This man was intensely disliked by many of
the poor workers in Medellin, who were being
laid off in droves by industrialists like
him.
Despite the family okaying the $50,000 ransom
demand, Echavarria was beaten, strangled and
the dumped in a ditch.
Even though he had just committed a terrible
crime, his choice of victim made Pablo hugely
popular among the common folk of Medellin.
In a strange way they saw the killing as Pablo
striking a blow for social equality.
Entering the Drug Trade
In 1971, the 22-year old Pablo began working
for Medellin based contraband dealer Alvaro
Prieto.
Under Prieto, Pablo was doing a modest amount
of drug trafficking.
Before long, however, he decided that he wanted
more of a slice of the pie for himself.
He drove his stolen Renault 4 to Ecuador and
bought five kilos of Peruvian cocaine paste.
Successfully passing through a number of police
and military checkpoints, he returned to Medellin,
where he processed the cocaine.
He next contacted fellow criminals the Ochoa
brothers to set up a sale to local cocaine
chief Fabio Restrepo.
The sale netted Pablo close to a hundred thousand
dollars, far surpassing anything he had previously
done, and setting him firmly on the path to
becoming a high-end drug dealer.
Within two months, Fabio Restrepo had been
murdered.
Suddenly there was a new man at the head of
the Medellin cocaine operation – Pablo Escobar.
It has never been conclusively proven that
Pablo murdered Restrepo, but that was what
everyone involved believed.
The majority of those working for Restrepo
were upper class dandies.
They were frightened by Pablo and the ruthless
hoodlums he surrounded himself with.
Shortly after muscling his way to the top
of the Medellin cocaine syndicate, Pablo married
fifteen-year-old Maria Victoria Helena Vellejo.
Now aged twenty-six, he had a wife, wealth
and power.
It seemed like the sky was the limit.
On Top
The cocaine trade from Panama, through Colombia
and into the United States boomed in the late
1970’s, with most of it being trafficked
though Escobar’s organization.
Under Pablo, the cocaine industry became streamlined.
He purchased a fleet of airplanes, including
a Lear jet to transport the drugs into the
United States where there was an inexhaustible
supply of willing buyers.
Two months after his wedding, Pablo and four
others were arrested after returning from
a drug run to Ecuador.
Drug enforcement agents found 39 kilos of
cocaine hidden in the spare tire of their
truck.
That amount of coke would see Pablo being
put away for a long time.
His first tactic in getting out of the mess
was to bribe the trial judge.
The offer however was flatly rejected.
Pablo then had his team research the judge’s
background.
They discovered that he had a brother who
was a lawyer and that the two men did not
get on.
The lawyer was contacted and offered a huge
amount to represent Pablo in the case.
As suspected, the judge was forced to recuse
himself due to conflict of interest.
The new judge didn’t have as many scruples
as the first.
He accepted a bribe and Pablo and his cohorts
walked free.
Exorbitant amounts of money were now pouring
into Colombia, with deposits in the country’s
four major banks doubling between 1976 and
1980.
Pablo was able to use his millions to take
possession of every step of his operation,
traveling to Peru, Bolivia and Panama and
buying up all the cultivation farms and processing
plants.
He was also able to buy off enforcement agencies
in every country, developing a ruthless policy
which came to be known as ‘plato o plomo’
– silver or lead.
If officials didn’t accept his bribe they
could expect to end up dead.
By 1980, Pablo was at the height of his power.
With every law enforcement agency on his payroll,
he was the unofficial king of Medellin.
He wasn’t the only cocaine impresario in
Colombia, but he was the most successful.
He owned multiple mansions, racing cars, helicopters
and planes and was constantly surrounded by
bodyguards and hangers on.
Cocaine money transformed Medellin, with discos
and high-end restaurants opening up all over
the city.
One of Pablo’s passions was soccer and now
he was able to indulge it.
He paid to have fields levelled and sodded
and lights installed so that he and his crew
could play at night time.
He would also employ professional game callers
to announce the matches as if they were an
FA cup final.
In 1979, Pablo built a lavish country estate
on a seventy-four-hundred-acre ranch, eighty
miles of Medellin, dubbing it Hacienda Los
Napoles.
He brought exotic animals from all over the
world to populate the farm, built six swimming
pools and a huge mansion that could sleep
a hundred guests.
At the same time that he was indulging his
every materialistic whim in private, Pablo
began tending to his public image.
He constantly denied that he was involved
in any illicit activity, portraying a formal,
likeable persona and appearing humble and
polite.
He consciously cultivated the image that he
was a freedom fighter for the underprivileged,
setting himself up as an alternative to the
establishment.
He also poured millions of dollars into social
construction programs.
Between 1980-1982, Pablo did more to help
out the poor in Medellin than the Colombian
government had ever done.
One of his most popular initiatives was a
housing project called Barrio Pablo Escobar,
where houses were built and given to families
who had previously been sheltering in shacks
at the city dump.
This and a host of other projects easily made
him the most popular citizen in Medellin.
In private, Pablo conducted himself in an
understated manner.
He spoke softly and was generally relaxed
and casual with those around him.
He was hugely self-indulgent - with food,
drink and women – and considered himself
a law unto himself.
On one occasion when an employee was found
to have stolen from him, Pablo had him brought
before him bound hand and foot and then kicked
him into the swimming pool, making everyone
watch as the man drowned.
A Brief Political Career
With his popularity among the masses firmly
established and his dominance over his empire
assured, the next logical step for Pablo was
politics.
His path to legitimate office began in 1978
when he was elected as a substitute city councillor
in Medellin.
In 1980 he gave his personal and financial
support to the formation of a new national
political movement, the New Liberal Party.
Then, in 1982 he ran for, and was elected
to Congress, albeit as a substitute who attended
when the primary delegate from Medellin was
unavailable.
A major perk of being elected to Congress
was that Pablo now had judicial immunity,
meaning that he could not be convicted for
a crime under Colombian law.
The position also afforded him a diplomatic
visa, which he made use of to regularly take
his family on trips to the United States.
On one trip he purchased an $8 million mansion
in Miami Beach, Florida.
Pablo now had political legitimacy to go with
his massive wealth.
The next acquisition was a personal army.
When a friend of the family was kidnapped
by M-19 guerrillas, he created a private militia
to hunt down the rebels.
Pablo’s army was known as ‘Death to Kidnappers.’
Pablo’s wider exposure as a result of his
political office was the beginning of his
downfall.
In Medellin he was viewed as a Robin Hood
figure, but when he tried to gain the favour
of polite Colombian society he was not welcomed.
They viewed him as what he really was – a
ruthless cocaine king with absolutely no scruples.
When he turned up to take his seat in Congress
as an alternate for the first time on August
16th 1983 with a bevy of bodyguards in tow
he was first denied entry for not wearing
a tie.
He quickly got hold of one and swept into
the packed chamber.
He slumped down in his allocated seat and
began nervously to bite his fingernails.
Immediately the Chamber president stood and
demanded that all bodyguards be removed from
the chamber.
Pablo nodded and his thugs left the room.
Within minutes Justice Minister Rodrigo Lara
was on his feet.
Defending a claim of corruption that had been
brought against him, Lara pointed the finger
at Pablo, stating . . .
We have a congressman who was born in a very
poor area himself, very, very poor, and afterwards,
through astute business deals in bicycles
and other things, appears with a gigantic
fortune, with nine planes, three hangars at
the Medellin airport and creates the Movement
‘Death to Kidnappers’, while on the other
hand, mounts charitable organizations with
which he tries to bribe a needy and unprotected
people.
And there are investigations going in the
United Sates, of which I cannot inform you
here tonight in the House, on the criminal
conduct of [Pablo Escobar].
Pablo said nothing in the House.
When he left he was besieged by reporters.
Breaking free, he stormed off.
Through his lawyer he informed Lara that if
he did not present evidence of his claims
within 24 hours he would face legal action.
Lara willingly obliged and in the coming days
the newspapers were filled with all sorts
of revelations about Pablo’s criminal activity.
Downfall
Pablo was now persona non-grata in political
circles.
He was kicked out of the New Liberal Party
and the US Embassy revoked his diplomatic
visa.
The Catholic church also renounced their support
of him.
The government even seized 85 of the exotic
animals on Pablo’s ranch claiming that they
had entered the country illegally.
Pablo’s political career was now in ruins.
Even worse for Pablo, the Colombia government,
at Lara’s urgings, were fast tracking an
extradition treaty with the US that would
see him tried in America for selling cocaine
in that country.
In May 1984, Justice Minister Lara was shoot
seven times while riding in his chauffer driven
limousine.
But Pablo had more powerful enemies.
US President Ronald Reagan had announced a
major crackdown on the cocaine trade.
With the death of Lara, the Colombian government
were willing to cooperate with American authorities
to go after Narco kingpins.
Pablo was the biggest of them all.
The killing of Lara also turned much of the
Columbian population against Pablo.
By the act he had declared war on the state.
For Pablo the heat was too much to bear and
he skipped the country, taking a helicopter
to Panama City.
Yet, despite being offered asylum in Panama
by President Manuel Noriega the year before,
Pablo and his cronies were not welcomed by
the authorities.
After just a few weeks in exile, Pablo was
desperate to get back home.
He made overtures to the Colombian government,
drafting a proposal whereby he would go straight
and use his massive influence to rid Colombia
of drug trafficking provided that he could
retain his possessions in Medellin and that
he would be exempt from arrest or extradition
to the US.
The offer was roundly rejected.
When the Panamanian army raided one of the
labs he had situated on the Colombian border
he fled Panama for Nicaragua.
Meanwhile, he was hearing that his absence
from Colombia was undermining his control
of the Medellin cartel.
The kidnapping of his 73-year-old father was
a step too far.
Pablo ordered a killing frenzy throughout
Medellin.
Dozens of suspected kidnappers were gunned
down.
Finally, the old man was released with no
ransom being paid.
All Out War
In the midst of the carnage over his father’s
kidnapping, Pablo returned to Colombia.
He was now determined to take on the state
with everything that he had.
Around Medellin he was untouchable, having
bought off every official.
This allowed him, although being the most
wanted man in the country, to move around
the town freely.
Pablo’s vengeful focus during the mid-80’s
was squarely centred on the judiciary, especially
judges who supported the extradition treaty
with the US.
During this time more than thirty judges were
shot dead.
Then, in November, 1985, the guerrilla group
M-19, having been paid a million dollars by
Pablo, stormed the Palace of Justice and held
the entire Supreme Court hostage.
They demanded that the government renounce
the extradition treaty.
In the resulting siege, 11 of the 24 justices,
along with 40 of the rebels, were killed.
By the beginning of 1988, killings were being
reported almost on a daily basis.
Martial law was declared in ordered to prevent
the state from toppling.
On August 18th, 1989 Pablo’s kill squads
gunned down both the front-running presidential
candidate Luis Galan and a state police chief.
In the following four months, the Colombian
government apprehended and sent more than
twenty suspected drug traffickers to the United
States to stand trial.
A national police unit was stationed to Medellin
specifically to hunt down Pablo.
Within the first month, 30 of the two hundred
men stationed there had been killed.
Pablo was evading his government and inflicting
enormous casualties, but he was a man constantly
on the run.
He always stayed a step ahead of his pursuers,
but he was growing tired of the constant relocations
needed to do so.
Eventually he agreed to negotiate.
Pablo agreed to put an end to the violence,
stop all criminal activity and hand himself
in.
In exchange he demanded preferential treatment
in a prison of his choosing and a reduced
settlement.
The government had already revoked the extradition
treaty to the US with its 1991 Constitution
so he didn’t have to worry about being sent
to America.
Pablo was duly arrested and tried.
He began his sentence at La Catedral prison
in June, 1991.
But this was like no other prison on earth.
It featured a football pitch, jacuzzi and
bar.
The prison guards were all employees of Pablo.
The prison cells were more like hotel suites
and the food that Pablo and his fellow inmates
ate was prepared by chefs who were brought
in from fine restaurants.
After a few months, accounts began to reach
official channels that Pablo was continuing
to pursue his criminal activities from La
Catedral.
This was a violation of the surrender agreement
and moves were put in place to seize him and
move him to a regular prison.
Pablo’s connections enabled him to get wind
of the plan and he escaped before the authorities
could get to him.
Fugitive
The hunt for Pablo was back on.
But now the US and Colombian authorities were
joined by a vigilante group known as Los Pepes,
which stood for ‘People Persecuted by Pablo
Escobar.’
Los Pepes carried out a ruthless campaign,
killing as many as three hundred people who
were connected to Pablo and his organization.
Following his escape from La Catedral, Pablo
was constantly on the run.
Most of his closest associates were dead and
his organization was falling apart.
He was spending nights sleeping in the jungle,
afraid to speak on the radio or to answer
the phone.
Fate finally caught up with Pablo Escobar
on December 2nd, 1993.
Members of a Colombian Search Bloc team had
tracked him down to house in the barrio of
Los Olivos in Medellin via radio intercepts.
The Search Bloc team smashed through the heavy
steel door with a sledgehammer, whereupon
six of them rushed into the house.
It was then that the shooting started.
In the house with Pablo was his most loyal
bodyguard, known as Limon.
They both bolted from the front room and made
their way up onto the roof.
The six Search Bloc members, along with others
outside poured a massive barrage of gunfire
at their targets.
Limon was hit several times in the back and
toppled to the ground below.
Then Pablo went down.
He was struck several times in the leg and
torso but the fatal shot penetrated his skull.
On confirming his target, the leader of the
operation spoke excitedly into his radio . . . ‘Viva
la Colombia – we have just killed Pablo
Escobar!’
But had they?
Pablo had always told his family that, if
cornered he would commit suicide by placing
a bullet in his skull.
Many people believe that he did so, once more
escaping the clutches of the Colombian authorities.